[Musique]
c'est le dernier bastion sur lequel la
vague macro nice tu n'as pas encore
déferlé au printemps 2010 est en marche
rêve de conquérir le sénat à peine
tourné la page d'une écrasante victoire
aux législatives le parti ouvre celle
des prochaines élections sénatoriales et
ose même parier sur quelques nouveaux
visages
bonjour madame je suis quelqu'un qui est
dans la vie réelle je fais pas partie de
l'ancienne classe politique tout en
misant sur l'expérience de personnages
plus aguerris je suis sénateur si je
suis réélu ce que je suis prêt à
travailler avec vous mais pendant l'été
une série d annonces du gouvernement va
mettre les grands électeurs en colère
des erreurs de communication qui vont
coûter cher aux candidats en marche au
mieux un siège le sénat est une maison
où l'on ne s'impose pas en quelques
semaines
c'est ici qu emmanuel macron va vivre
son premier revers électoral
[Musique]
première étape dans la conquête du sénat
la création d'un groupe avant l'été à la
manoeuvre
françois patriat sénateur de la côte
d'or cet ancien socialiste est l'un des
premiers à avoir rallié emmanuel macron
au moins de juin ce très proche du
président lance est tous les sénateurs
macron compatible un appel à intégrer le
futur groupe des marcheurs pour
convaincre ceux qui hésitent d'equipe
affûte ses arguments d'abord la
recomposition qui n'épargne pas le parti
qui n'étaient pas les leurs qui font un
score minable le ps son avis le dernier
automne de l'ultra d'epinay m et 2 les
années futures police marianne et le
fait que la médiature
c'est un sésame une 15 partenaires il
faudra qu'on se dise aujourd'hui voilà
aujourd'hui en étant mais on peut déjà
compter sur un certain nombre de
parlementaires d'ores et déjà viendront
groupe toyota qui ne fera en juin seuls
quatre sénateurs sont officiellement en
marche pour former un groupe au sénat il
faut être au moins dix optimiste
françois patriat espérant rallier bien
plus il faut que ce groupe soit
conséquent donc ce groupe ne peut pas
être un groupe pro pire au sénat
moi je souhaite si nous devons faire ce
groupe avant la session d'été qui les 40
mans à midi les moins deux on y va
moi j'y vais j'ai tout ça
l'objectif est ambitieux pour
l'atteindre
les marcheurs espère puiser dans les
troupes socialistes depuis l'élection d'
emmanuel macron blur groupe est très
divisé sur la ligne adoptée face au
gouvernement
la droite compte aussi une réserve de
sénateurs macron compatibles mais ils
sont plus difficiles à khalid
joran chanter arnaud sanchez je m'occupe
de la création du groupe luke en marche
au sénat je me permets de vous contacter
parce qu'on cherche à joindre la
sénatrice du rang dont on sait ça
duranton parce qu'on va lui proposer de
rejoindre le nouveau groupe
on a besoin de sénateur au sénatrice
mauvaise ils viennent de la droite
pendant une semaine l'équipe enchaîne
les coups de fil pour aller chercher les
sénateurs un par un une conférence de
presse est prévue fin juin pour annoncer
la création officielle du groupe vont
être très franc la conférence de presse
aura lieu demain matin à 10 heures donc
bien bien avant si possible avant 8
heures demain matin avant les familles
sains et où donc
qui on a eu un tendre non mes carnets il
vous faut qu'il me connaît on est encore
diminuer dans une semaine on est une
gauche qui rencontre des arts show
convaincre françois patriat leur promet
des investitures aux sénatoriales qui
ont lieu trois mois plus tard dix mois
ah la la
ce matin là j'ai siégé à la commission
d'investiture n'y aura pas de problème
pour thoiras et hakim un ok 1 qui se
recrutent et sera investi par ans
marchait pas de problème ok voilà donc
je voulais te le dire tant on a n'a posé
aucun problème on était en commission
restreinte
donc ça va ça va aller deuxièmement je
laisse à mort parce que je fais le
groupe demain ou après demain photo mais
en fait groupe savoir comment tu te
positionner par rapport au groupe en
marche
est ce que tu souhaites venir ou est ce
que tu souhaites rester voilà malgré les
promesses les sénateurs rechignent à
quitter leur famille politique et les
marcheurs manque de temps
[Musique]
le lendemain un temps la presse est
invitée au palais du luxembourg pour
l'annoncé officielle de la création du
groupe en marche la liste rassemble 25
sénateurs
la quasi totalité est issu des rangs
socialistes
il ya aujourd'hui 26 noms qui sont 25
ans qui sont signés adhéré avec dedans
nos amis qu'ultramar un 4 5 1 litres à
marin qui nous ont rejoints 4 pour
l'instant on est bien loin de l'objectif
des 40 membres fixé au départ par
françois patriat les avec 25 sénateurs
son groupe parti de zéro devient la 4e
force du sénat il reste confiant
ce groupe qui aujourd'hui est un groupe
qui est déjà constituée qui est
largement va vous répondre à vos
questions
largement le nombre de parlementaires
nécessaires à vocation à s'agrandir
je vous le dis dès maintenant et les
mêmes vocation à devenir après la
rentrée parlementaire
le deuxième groupe du sida c'est notre
objectif
[Musique]
devenir la deuxième force du sénat cette
fois encore l'objectif est ambitieux
après des aliments tardif le groupe
atteint 29 membres pour se hisser à la
deuxième place il faut monter à 60
sénateurs
bonjour madame on vient déposer
l'ensemble des documents pour la
création du groupe
la république en marche
pour étoffer son groupe françois patriat
compte sur les élections sénatoriales
mais il n'aura pas la main sur le choix
des candidats
[Musique]
au sénat les investitures se joue dans
les couloirs et les salons feutrés loin
du regard des caméras
jean paul delevoye y multiplie les
entretiens avec des sénateurs de tous
bords
c'est lui qui préside la commission
d'investiture dans marche pour les
élections sénatoriales de l'été infra
voulait chercher des adhérents mais vous
avez plein non ne cherchons pas des
marches cherchons des gens qui défiait
écrit la carte des étoiles
tour à tour député sénateur ministre
c'est un homme de réseau et il sait qu
aux sénatoriales la tâche sera plus
compliquée pour en marche qu'au
législatives dans ce scrutin indirect ce
ne sont pas tous les citoyens qui votent
mais des grands électeurs pour la
plupart des élus municipaux et aux
dernières municipales en marche
n'existait pas nous ne pouvons pas avoir
un raisonnement qui consiste à dire je
prends quelqu'un de la société civile
parce qu'il est talentueux
parce qu'il est qu'il est porteur de une
formidable capacité d'empathie bien ça
ne suffit pas parce qu'ils font qu'ils
soient au coeur du corps électoral pour
pouvoir au contraire capter les grands
électeurs qui n'ont pas du tout les
mêmes réflexes hacker des citoyens par
rapport à par rapport à une candidature
légistatives
[Musique]
difficile dans ces conditions de jouer
la carte du renouveau cher en marche
les travaux de la commission
d'investitures piétine les listes
attendue mi juillet ne seront publiés
que fin août les candidats investis
n'ont plus qu'un mois pour faire
campagne dans le lot c'est agnès symonds
piquet qui porte les couleurs dans
marche mer des junies ce une petite
ville de 300 habitants elle se lance
dans sa première campagne sénatoriale
bonjour aux gendarmes ont validé le four
maire de saint sulpice année symonds
piquet candidate aux sénatoriales
la candidate vient faire connaissance
avec des grands électeurs qu'elle n'a
jamais rencontrée je suis quelqu'un qui
est dans la vie réelle je fais pas
partie de l'ancienne classe politique je
travaille à plein de temps j'ai trois
enfants de 25 et 23 ans qui me
permettent de bien voir les difficultés
qu'ont les jeunes à rentrer sur le
marché de l'emploi
aujourd'hui je suis graphiste
mais ma formation à la base c'est du
droit de l'économie des sciences
sociales au côté de son directeur de
campagne
elle déroule son cv comme pour un
entretien dans gauche en tout cas merci
beaucoup pour votre accueil le ciel et
voilà c'est toujours très intéressant de
pouvoir échanger et de connaître mieux
les communes merci beaucoup au revoir
pour faire campagne
agnès symonds piquet est dû poser cinq
semaines de congés sans solde
cet ancien socialiste a rejoint en
marche l'élection présidentielle au
volant de sa voiture elle sillonne les
routes du département
j'ai connu d'autres partis politiques où
il y avait vraiment un staff derrière
tout ce qui est communication pour tout
ce qui est organisation tout était là
rodez l'a fait tout nous-mêmes
un véritable marathon pour tenter de
rencontrer le plus d'élus possible dans
les 322 communes du lot alors l'amérique
pardon d'espédaillac je dirais avaya
l'église à chaque étape devant chaque
maire il faut dénoncer encore le même
discours de présentation dont gemini
vous connaissez pas voilà donc je fais
pas partie de l'ancienne classe
politique après je suis quelqu'un qui
travaille à plein temps j'ai trois
enfants bien sûr moi si je suis élu je
l'intégrerai le groupe en marche au
sénat mais on voudrait créer je sais pas
si c'est un une commission sous groupes
ou je ne sais quoi d'élus ruraux pour
pouvoir travailler
agnès symonds piquet visite une dizaine
de mairie par jour tout en sachant
qu'elle ne pourra pas voir tout le monde
ça fonctionne je n'ai pas encore pris ma
décision
j'attends d'avoir vu l'ensemble des
candidats bon ce jour j'ai dû y avoir 4
5 mais moi ce qui me b je dirais dans la
démarche à marche c'est le fait que en
est un pour projet de faire travailler
les gens de quelque bord qu'ils soient
sur des dossiers qui sont d'intérêt
national son côté novice elle tente de
le tourner à son avantage en misant tout
sur une promesse de renouveau car la
candidate n'a pas de bilan à mettre en
avant c'est sûrement moins facile parce
que c'est vrai qu'un sénateur sortant
bas c'est vrai qu'il a déjà distribué de
l'envelope donc les gens le connaissent
les gens et compte sur lui encore pour
faire avancer des projets moi j'arrive
j'ai pas de promesse à donner sur des
enveloppes sur des sommes à 700 km de là
jean marie vanlerenberghe mène une
campagne d'un autre genre sénateur
depuis 16 ans il connaît déjà la plupart
des grands électeurs du pas de calais
formidable accueilli c'est toujours il
est la tête de liste on marche dans le
pas de calais tout en gardant son
étiquette modem soutenu par le député du
coin
il vient rencontrer des élus inquiet à
propos du futur canal seine nord
le projet doit permettre de relier
l'europe du nord au bassin de la seine
alors c'est moi je vis bien c'est que
les vertus pour contre le canard mais
vaut bien qu'ils passent ailleurs pour
faire passer le canal
il faut creuser à 45 mètres de
profondeur ce qui revient à couper le
village en deux mais pas au courant de
rien ben voilà voilà un beau sujet pour
monsieur le député je suis sénateur si
je suis réélu c'est ce que je suis pas
travailler avec vous
pour montrer aux candidats les
conséquences concrètes du projet les
élus l'emmène sur le site du futur canal
au revoir
de travail des idées pour améliorer le
projet les élus locaux en ont plein mais
ils ont bien du mal à les faire entendre
au lieu en europe pour nous aider parce
que nous nous seuls représentants de la
commune on y arrivera pas je suis là bas
je suis là ça me ça m'intéresse venu
nous sommes sera plus forte que la nôtre
abbas père est en tous les cas je vais
contacter jeu la tactique au
un poids dans les minutes être sénateur
depuis 16 ans c'est un atout précieux
dans une campagne sénatoriale
il a quand même qu'à quelques pas mal
d'années de sénateurs derrière lui c'est
sûr que ça compte ça c'est certain il a
l'expérience aussi maintenant oui ça
c'est c'est sûr pour nous c'est
important aussi de savoir que on aura un
sénateur pas loin et qui a de
l'expérience
voilà pourquoi on marche a aussi misé
sur ce type de profil un candidat de 78
ans pas vraiment l'archétype du
renouveau incarné par les jeunes
marcheurs
mais le sénateur modem est très bien
implanté sur son territoire et c'est
précisément ce qui fait défaut aux
parties des manuels macron leurs
questions c'est en a besoin de vous on a
besoin d'être soutenue on a besoin
d'être accompagné
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de questions qui
ne trouvent pas pour le moment de
réponse je suis là pour ça
[Musique]
dans le lot
agnès symonds piquet continue
d'enchaîner les rendez vous en mairie
dans son discours elle cite souvent mot
pour mot les paroles du président les
jantes
là je le cite les territoires savent
mieux l'organisation qui a la plus
pertinente pour eux pas de nouveau big
bang territorial un rôle de petit soldat
du mécanisme qui se retourne parfois
contre elle et une évaluation sur
l'efficacité des contrats aidés
ils se sont aperçus que savait pas
d'efficacité sur sur le chômage que
finalement je suis tout à fait d'accord
que le fait de le supprimer
oui voilà après six sur l'arrêt colonies
connaissances sur le fond le fond et la
forme ira ce sera pareil
c'est facile pour équilibrer le budget
la suppression des contrats aidés nous
avons six postes à l'école nous
aujourd'hui nous avons
moore en passant par des personnes qui
ne semblent plus aider nos budgets ne le
supporteront pas à bien fin des contrats
aidés suppression de la taxe
d'habitation baisse des dotations aux
collectivités
pendant l'été le gouvernement a enchaîné
les annonces des mesures prises
impopulaire auprès des élus locaux
il faut se battre nous il faut qu'on
fasse en fait le monsois didactique on
explique qu'on explique mais pas
pédagogique la pédagogie
c'est pas toujours simple parce que même
nous parfois des choses qu'on comprend
complètement mais c'est ça moi je suis
monsieur mâcon en fait partie puis est
arrivé
ce croteau au qg de jean marie
vanlerenberghe
on prépare le tract du candidat qui sera
envoyée à tous les grands électeurs
qu'est ce que tu veux mettre un trait et
dotation d'une baisse rampant d'affelay
corrigeant bas jeudi
les dotations besson qu'en 2018
il n'y aura pas de nouvelle loi points
il n'y aura pas de nouvelle loi
territoriale
durant le mandat et la liberté ça sera à
l'essai voilà on va mettre ça comme ça
on a effectivement un drive nationale ou
en marche mais les éléments de langage
des fiches défense des fiches riposte
des fugues voilà on nous demande aussi
un moment vie voilà peut-être un peu
plus offensif dans le pas-de-calais
aussi les annonces de l'été se sont
invités dans la campagne
pas de quoi inquiéter le sénateur
sortant avec le temps il a appris à
esquiver les sujets qui fâchent
édification c'est quand même tout un art
que de savoir ce qu'il faut et jusqu'où
aller quand on parle aux élus et quel
est le message qui peut être aujourd'hui
entendues par les élus certains vont
s'arrêter ou contrat aidé je suis en pas
faire la campagne quand on dit sommaire
pas faire la campagne sur les contrats
aidés
ça fait rigoler quoi si vous n'êtes pas
aguerris vous plonger le panneau il est
là je vous rentrez dedans sur la
la taxe d'habitation elles vont nous
expliquer où il va prendre sur me
retraité une cg vous serez pas affecté
madame j'étais je suis deux ans je la
lis pas beaucoup 1200 mais je sais pas
mais moi je suis là aussi pour défendre
effectivement les salaires les plus
faibles et il ya un plafond est à un
plancher à 1200 euros
je dis pas que c'est gagné symonds
piquet argumente tant bien que mal mais
la colère des élus est réel et commence
à compromettre sérieusement les chances
des candidats en marche
on sera loin du raz-de-marée vraiment
loin du raz-de-marée les essentiellement
à cause des
des premières mesures qui ont été prises
tout simplement
[Musique]
vous
à noter le 24 septembre plus de 3000
grands électeurs sont convoqués pour
élire les sept sénateurs du pas de
calais jean marie vanlerenberghe et en
terrain familier
il sait qu'il peut compter sur un réseau
d'élus qui lui sont fidèles
la santé sexuelle car avec points c'est
sûr merci bonne journée
[Musique]
en nageant l'année
les résultats vigoureux 16 heures 15h30
sera quoi je suis confiant évidemment
mais un peu quand même inquiet pour
et
savoir quelle sera effectivement le
score est si nous courons comme nous
l'espérons
faire élire deux candidats de notre
liste
[Musique]
dans le lot deux sièges de sénateurs
sont en jeu agnès symonds piquet
espérant décrocher un
dès la première heure elle vient de
glisser son bulletin dans l'urne moins
de trois mois je le sens bien ça s'est
bien passé
on va voir on va voir suspense
[Musique]
jusqu'au bout elle a jeté toutes ses
forces dans cette campagne
mais elle réalise que le temps lui un an
qu'il bonjour monsieur je le plus
frustrant c'est de se dire je vois des
délégués que je connais pas je n'ai pas
pu les rencontrer parce qu'elle va ya
des gens qui travaillent qui n'ont pas
pu venir au reina et je peux dit mais
quel dommage on ne pas avoir eu un
contact avant en fin d'après midi
le scrutin est clos jean marie
vanlerenberghe suit le dépouillement de
très près
on s'est rappelé de raconter ta petite
7h10
table génial très vite il comprend que
le résultat s'annonce beaucoup moins
bons que prévu c'est pas terrible mais
bon faut avoir c'est variable suivant
les tables donc on verra
mais
ta phrase vaut mieux un siège
c'est
comme ça c'est tout
ça me suffit
[Musique]
oh
en jeunes prévue demain à la préfecture
du lot le décompte des voix annonce un
résultat serré agnès symonds piquet
préfère s'isoler
elle semble ne plus y croire vraiment
merci mon dieu
normalement
sans gêne et 17h les résultats tombent
dans le pas de calais pour l'année où le
parc sur puis 118 suffrages fois le ciel
ou la nuit
le pas de calais en a donc vite par
monsieur wang wenbin 520 de visual soit
[Applaudissements]
le sénat ce fut
petit peu tordu qui c'est jean marie
vanlerenberghe est réélu mais sa liste
en marche ne remporte qu'un seul siège
alors que deux sénateurs sont élus à
droite et quatre à gauche
[Musique]
culture face à la fronde des élus
le candidat n'a pas pu faire mieux que
de sauver son siège au national c'est
patent c'est peut-être que le
gouvernement va prendre conscience qu'il
ya un truc qui va pas c'est pas
seulement de dire on n'avait pas de base
on n'avait pas de ceux ci n'ont la
communication alors moi je veux bien
défendre le gouvernement mais quand eux
on ne sait pas communiquer je peux pas
défendre l'indéfendable
un peu plus tard le dépouillement
s'achève dans le lot
agnès symonds piquet échoue à quelques
voix près
on
[Musique]
pour les facilement
pourtant on a fait ce qu'on a pu bon
comme c'est beau non c'est pas beau non
c'est pas beau mais ça marche parce que
tu es venu
[Musique]
la candidate a du mal à masquer sa
déception elle a le sentiment de payer
les maladresses d'un gouvernement qui
s'est mis à dos les élus toutes les
annonces qui ont été faites au mois
d'août
toutes ces choses là enfin le
gouvernement aurait voulu nous faire
couler il s'y serait pas pris autrement
je le dis gentiment et c'est un peu ça
donc plus la presse les médias au mois
d'août aussi qu'ils ont fait un battage
terrible mois quand j'arrivais dans les
communes on s'adressait à monsieur
macron s'adressait pas à la candidate
voilà donc après si elles justifiées
d'expliquer les choses mais ça n'a pas
suffi
[Musique]
a paris le groupe en marche au sénat
compile les résultats nationaux et les
mauvaises nouvelles s'accumulent
facebook
sur 171 sièges renouvelables au sénat
seuls seize candidats investis par en
marche ont été élus le parti prépare les
éléments de langage pour minimiser la
défaite et station bien sûr que c'est
important de conforter l'idée n'est
possible au sénat l'objectif majeur des
nageurs seront construits c'est des cons
qui plonge un peu plus dans celle
concernant son enfance à son arrivée
françois patriat n'a pas vraiment la
mine des grands jours
ça va aller
[Musique]
le parti
son équipe le brief à peine quelques
minutes
et très vite il faut aller répondre aux
questions des journalistes
faire bonne figure surtout ne pas parler
d'échec
il y à de nombreuses département où des
candidats la république en marche échoue
à quelques dizaines de voix parfois même
à quelques voix dont on aurait pu être
plus nombreux
bien maintenant pour le la république en
marche pour le mouvement le gouvernement
pour le chef de l'état
il s'agit d'une première page après la
page blanche que nous sommes partis au
mois de juin
quelques jours plus tard vient la
première réunion post électorales du
groupe au sénat avant l'élection les
marcheurs étaient 29
désormais ils ne sont plus que 21 des
nouveaux prétorienne
le groupe n'est que la quatrième force
du sénat loin très loin derrière
l'objectif de départ de françois patriat
premier temps gilles en avant l'été il
espérait atteindre les 60 sénateurs et
devenir le deuxième groupe de la chambre
haute le fait d'un groupe et reste pour
moi un objectif
j'aurais pas dû à l'époque chiffre est
notre objectif nous la reprocher je
crois que c'était vie est faite
franchissent tu m'as pas mais quand vous
créez un groupe que tu ex nihilo
- vision vous êtes 30 espérer le doublé
c'est quand même une ambition légitime
quatrième au classement
le groupe n'est pas en position de force
pour faire passer les réformes promises
par emmanuel macron il faudra se battre
texte un prétexte pour construire des
majorités de circonstance
les marcheurs voulait conquérir le
palais du luxembourg
c'est finalement par la petite porte
qu'ils sont entrés au sénat
[Musique]